myriam bonsoir il ya le minitel rose le
répondeur rose qu est-ce qu à l'eau de
rose hill réseau rose et puis elle
téléphone euros soit tu bosses dans le
téléphone rose non moi j'ai essayé un
jour voilà comment ça se passe c'est à
dire si je me trompe
alors on regarde un numéro de téléphone
dans le nouvel observateur
c'est là où il ya le plus non non non
non support support nationaux sont quand
même union
ouais vidéo c'est en a des tas d'autres
voient dans la plage pierre mas aussi
bien en tant que marque et 200 francs la
conversation cartes de crédit acceptées
alors dos en france et pas tous les
téléphones bon ça commence à 150
ça peut aller jusqu'à 300 mais encore le
prix diffèrent selon si le client vos
deux hôtesses par exemple sans avoir de
voilà que ça je savais pas tu as déjà
j'apprends des trucs alors au téléphone
donc on vous dit comment vous vous
appelez votre prénom
bon je trais on peut dire sans le prêt
on peut dire à votre prénom
oui bien sûr moi je suis trop honnête
peut-être alors apprendre demande mon
numéro de carte de crédit carte bleue
plutôt que l'american express mois là tu
vas faire un standard tout ça ce côté là
les hôtesses ne l'ont pas vraiment pas
bon ensuite on me rappelle ont
grandement numéro de téléphone en me
rappelle est en demande de choisir entre
la salle plat dominatrice cascades haute
dans le choix d'abord on propose si le
client veut une hôtesse blonde une
hôtesse brunante à ce poste et je vais
commencer à être fait non c'est comme ça
on peut demander si on veut une fille
jeunes au contraire une femme plus âgée
souvent le client pense qu'une femme
plus âgée a plus d'expérience au client
de le découvrir
et en dehors de ça donc on propose toute
une gamme de spécialités c'est donc la
domination la soumission l'urologie
scatologie inceste viol zoophilie
effectivement dans l'assaut au fini si
vous voulez une hôtesse attendant c'est
au fil
cela peut être différente sort d'animer
ce qu'elle va faire la vidéo téléphone
elle va faire des bruits d'animaux
nous avons des bruitages qui sont déjà
pré-enregistrées au départ et donc
l'hôtesse qui effectivement peut-être
adeptes ne pas l'être ça sera toujours
le mystère de la conversation vous
aiguillera sur bon c'est le chien quand
même le plan c'est le chien c'est le
chien et les gros chiffres les gens
veulent entendre des bruits de chiottes
quand il téléphone assez compliqué moi
j'en ai beaucoup pressé le petit câlin
le solde du callao retire pornographie
plutôt pornographiques en même temps par
nouba way avant de faire dodo comme ça
mais pas alors à ce moment là
effectivement vous pouvez avoir une
conversation avec une hôtesse beaucoup
plus porno beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
vicieuse qui vous emmènera au septième
ciel pourquoi pas moi je m'imaginais
quand je téléphonais à ce truc là que la
fille c'est une vieille avec des
bigoudis qui tricoter avec un micro bar
est en train de lire un texte comme ça
alors j'ai demandé à marc arrive de
faire une enquête là-dessus c'est comme
ça qu'on est là qu'on a rencontrés et en
fait pas du tout vous travaillez pas du
tout 1
non non absolument pas travailler dans
des salons quoi on nie d'abord dans une
grande pièce puisque standard avec les
standardistes passe quand même plus
sympa d'être tout le monde ancien et
comme on essaye de répartir les appels
bon s'il ya trois blondes une fois c'est
une fois la deuxième et la troisième se
croient plus de la même façon
non ce qu'il ya c'est que chaque hôtesse
à prévoir dans une petite pièce donc
toute seule elle s'isole avec son client
ce qui fait qu'on sait pas ce qui se
passe où elle se masturbe où elle prend
son pied où elle le prend pas l'eau
bonjour aujourd'hui moi comment tu
t'appelles tu t'appelles pierre bonjour
pierre moi c'est myriam comment tuer
physiquement pierre tp tipi les bras et
je n'ai pas mariées célibataires c'est
intéressant
dis-moi du partage un petit fantasme
avec moi un gros qu'elle est un fantasme
moi je crois bien j'ai jamais vu ça sera
une première
tu fais ça depuis longtemps quoi trois
en trois ans trois ans et alors tu fais
ça tu keller à coeur mais ça dépend on a
des roulements il ya des tranches
horaires de 9h à 18h avec une heure
d'interruption pour le déjeuner la
désert de soirée 18 heures 2 heures du
matin et comme ça fonctionnent non-stop
cela fonctionne la nuit également il ya
des hôtesses de nuit
il ya des hôtesses de week-end et on a
toujours la possibilité de permuter nos
horaires entre une hôtesse et les à
peine sept cas leurs acquéreurs quand
même plus c'est pas la même clientèle
la clientèle de journée c'est une
clientèle de personnes cadres moyens et
cadres supérieurs
je pense que les gens qui font ça au
bureau alors tout à fait tout à fait
puisque l'on est des cartes de crédit de
la société non non ça quand même pas
nous on est obligé d'avoir une carte de
crédit est tout à fait né natif
donc effectivement il y en a qui
appellent de leur société les minitels
ils ont réussi à bloquer ça mais bon
pour le téléphone comme ils servent de
leur téléphone donc là y'a aucune
impunité les mecs qui font ça qui ferme
la queue avec les leur bureau qui
fonçait dans leur bureau voilà et disent
à leur secrétaire de ne pas les déranger
ça peut être une petite conférence où ça
peut être la pause déjeuner salade et
des idéaux janvier dans cette émission
non mais elle a quand même qu'ils
appellent de chez eux par exemple
électeurs d'union c'est souvent des
couples qui nous appellent aussi oui
mais tu crois qu'ils mettent le sens
plus fort sur le téléphone à ce qu'on
mandate un ampli à y mettre un ampli qu
il ya des amplis dans tous les foyers
maintenant effectivement il met un ampli
est comme ça on peut soit leur donner un
petit peu la direction à prendre les
diriger ou concernant les jets des
couples ou télécommandées les couples en
fait oui où on est on essaye d'être la
troisième personne qu'ils aimeraient
avoir un ouais c'est génial on a aussi
des femmes qui osent appeler des femmes
qui peuvent
oui mais en face c'est vraiment une
petite minorité ça représente à peine 5
à 10 % c'est peut-être pas parce
qu'elles n'ont pas de fantasme et c'est
parce qu'elles ont besoin de concret
est-ce que vous avez des
des accessoires ah oui alors
effectivement il ya aussi donc par miner
et spécialistes il ya donc des
spécialistes en domination qui ne font
que de la domination à l'oral elles ont
à leur disposition effectivement fouet
martinez god de toutes les tailles etc
vu que c'est par téléphone que ça peut
faire elle n'est pas anti néo ouaga
juste mois le client qui veut une
conversation avec une dominatrice quant
à lui dit tiens je te donne un coup de
fouet il faut quand même que le gars
puissent tout à fait imaginer ça
l'hôtesse a donc le fou et elle le fait
claquer le mec est au téléphone et on
entend le gars qui crie effectivement
j'ai été content bah oui puisque c'est
ce qu'il veut et une fois que c'est fini
le mec il dit merci d'y arriver un petit
mot gentil me raccroche ça dépend
souvent quand c'est des fantasmes très
particulier comme scatologie et c'est
nous mêmes effectivement domination
après ils ont un peu honte et cela
raccroche gouverna qui s'assume tout à
fait alors que le petit câlin érotique
ou pornographique ça s'arrête pas comme
ça y'a pas une posture
après bon ça va mieux puisqu'il est
complètement libérée la semaine voilà
quatre partants bien donc
lui dit est ce que ça t'a plu quand tu
veux tu nous re téléphone pour un petit
câlin quand tu te sens seul
qu'est ce que tu vas faire maintenant
alors sous le nom de boucher sinon
prendre un petit café où ils vont dormir
dormir et 10 dans tes spécialisée dans
quoi toi à moi c'est le petit câlin
porno l'urologie tout seul
non là il ya des spécialistes pour
l'urologie scatologie senti robinet
alors à ben alors là il ya deux verres
il y en a un qui est remplie pierre est
évident
bon évidemment les filles elle peut pas
elle peut pas uriner à ce moment là
alors elle prend le verre et puis
évident sur l'autre en disant je sens je
suis en train de faire dessus temps bien
c'est sûr et c'est assez ce qu'ils
mangent et est-ce qu'il ya des clients
réguliers par exemple est-ce que tu
arrives à nouer une relation avec un mec
qui appellerait souvent comme ça on a
des relations d'amitié moi j'ai un
client qui s'appelle daniel qui
m'appelle très très souvent je voyais
ces anonymes moi je vois très bien que
ça c'est pas évident non non on a des
clients habitués il y en a des
occasionnels qui essaient à qui ce n'est
pas du tout leur truc alors bon cela ne
récidive pas quand la conversation
continue dur que le mec qui arrive pas
ça peut durer combien de temps je veux
dire le plus long c'est quoi c'est les
mecs ça doit durer 30 secondes ou une
minute ou deux minutes non mais ça c'est
des lapins cinq ans c'est pas beaucoup
n'y avait pas beaucoup
non non c'est très rare c'est quoi la
moyenne des appels la durée moyenne la
durée pour qu'un homme puisse jouir faut
compter 8 à 10 minutes ça quand même 8 à
10 minutes bon il y en a qui vont plus
vite mon équipe parce que moi là on leur
parle on s'intéresse à nos valeurs nous
racontent leur combi autre chose et
c'est pas nous qui est le vrai qu'il n'y
arrive pas ça peut durer quand même
temps je dois s'imaginent que vous
m'avez bien fait mais qu'elle soit
toujours pas arrivé oui alors là c'est
grave parce qu'effectivement on peut
quand même pas dû rester des heures à
nous également
non on veut pas parler de rendement non
mais ce qui se passe c'est qu'on peut
rien pour eux à ce moment là tu sais y
en a aussi qui ne se déshabille pas
comment veux-tu qu'un gars puissent
effectivement jouir en se brûlant si il
a habillé avec son costume
c'est chaud c'est un étranger sur le lit
quand même oui c'est nous demander
comment on est d'ailleurs à la physique
on a aussi des gens qui nous appellent
de l'étranger
l'appel le plus loin que j'ai reçus
fallait deux appels le plus loin ça a
été la nouvelle zélande et l'australie
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu